hallo ließ wieder einmal waren und
willkommen zum gleichen interview fünf
jahre später wie es letztens aufgefallen
dass ich schon ziemlich lange youtube
mache auch wirklich wenn mich jemand
fragt sag ich immer so you're seit drei
jahren und dabei sind es schon über fünf
jahre
man kann ja bei den youtube videos
schauen hinzugefügt am ältesten zuerst
und wenn ich das beim einem kanal mache
ist es ein großes crash es für mich für
euch wahrscheinlich auch jeder youtuber
muss ich natürlich erst entwickeln man
lebt nicht das erste video hoch und hat
die geilste quali und die besten witze
und den schönsten redefluss nein am
anfang ist man halt auch noch etwas
schüchtern bin ich natürlich heute nicht
mehr heute bin ich die youtube queen
befreundet
ich wollte sagen ich bin heute cool und
lässig und locker und alles was ich auf
diesem kanal macht es mir eigentlich
auch egal hauptsache man sieht man
schmeckt auch nicht aber das ist mir
alles egal
und bei diesem crash fest meiner alten
videos bin ich auf ein video gestoßen
das letzte käfer heißt es war mein
erstes quasi interview wo ich eure
fragen beantwortet habe und dann habe
ich mich an das video von billy idol
erinnert dass ihr vielleicht auch
geschaut hat wo sie alle interviewfragen
ein jahr später noch mal beantwortet
this is what we gonna do to date
willkommen bei heads base und ich würde
sagen hey leute ich wieder eure mal
wanne ich mache seit über fünf jahren
da schreibt mir mal bitte in die
kommentare findet ihr meine begrüßung
gut habt ihr schon so daran gewöhnt dass
ihr sie nicht wissen wollt oder denkt
ihr kommt man es nach fünf jahren ist
man darüber gehen und wie schlecht die
kamera qualität war gut dass ich ein
bisschen geld verdient habe und mir
besseres equipment leisten konnte danke
euch wie wär's mit diesen typischen
lieblings gabler fragen ok immer noch
okay jetzt eigentlich dein bruder oder
nicht weil das alles sagen
stimmt es dass du ja kuss schwester und
freundin bist das ist so kompliziert ist
froh du wirklich dein bruder wie alle
sagen was hältst du von fleisch wurst
für die leute die es nicht wissen ich
war mal mit fotoapparat zusammen und war
mit jako von future befreundet falls
euch die beiden namen nicht sagen google
is your friend und das war wohl
interessant zu der zeit was genau
bedeutet dein tattoo am abend also eine
richtige bedeutung haben die jetzt nicht
möglich es sind ein paar tattoos dazu
gekommen ich habe jetzt nicht nur das
origami ding hier und den pinsel sondern
auch eine pocahontas mit einem move und
einem blumenstrauß am arm eine tasse die
ich mir in london spontan stechen lassen
habe die ich super hässlich finde ein
fussel an der achsel tattoo hab ich auch
ein vogel den ich super schön finde und
den harry potter blitz dazu ankaufen
rücken aber natürlich habe ich noch ganz
viele andere tattoo wünsche da hast du
geschwister wenn ja verstehst du dich
gut mit ihnen ja ich verstehe mich gut
mit meinen geschwistern ich habe eine
schwester und zwei brüder und wir haben
uns alle ganz doll lieb ich habe immer
noch eine schwester und zwei brüder und
mittlerweile habt ihr auch meinen bruder
kennengelernt also meinen jüngeren
trotzdem ein älterer aber der jüngere
von den beiden und ich habe sie immer
noch alle wirklich sehr lieb hast du
eigentlich so eine vorstellung was du
mal mit deinem kanal machen möchtest
oder möchtest du das erstmal so weiter
machst ich bin eigentlich ganz zufrieden
so wie meine gerade läuft ich würde mir
wünschen dass ich natürlich immer
abonnenten erreichen aber das ist es
kommt gleich mit der zeit aber netzer
ist kam mitte zeit wir haben jetzt mehr
abonnenten
ich habe auf jeden fall spaß bei wanne
will's wissen ich liebe es irgendwelche
sachen auszuprobieren und ich hoffe dass
ich noch coolere oder noch ganz
verschiedene sachen irgendwie hinkriege
was sich in zukunft vielleicht mal
ausprobieren möchte ist mehr so
mädchenkram dann einfach irgendwie mal
dazwischen so ein mädchen aufbauen
können wir mal darüber reden wie
unglaublich süß ich war ich meine
mädchen ecke haben jetzt nicht wirklich
aufgebaut aber ich habe ab und zu mal
beauty videos gemacht und wann er will
es wissen war ein format das ich nicht
mehr mache aber wo ich sachen getestet
habe also besonders so spielset / i mate
ganz viele andere sachen das intro war
aber das beste weine will's wissen und
wo möchte ich jetzt mit meinem kanal hin
also ich möchte auf jeden fall noch mehr
abonnenten also das wäre toll
die million zu erreichen ich bin aber
froh wie es ist und ich bin gerade in so
einer schönen wechselphase merke ich
aber schön für mich weil ich mich
einfach gerade weiterentwickelt und ja
ich mache einfach weiter ich meine bis
jetzt läuft und drei kopfball an kommt
auch wieder bald keine sorgen wie kommst
du auf deine video ideen
alte andré es glaubt doch kein mensch
dass ich so auf meine video ideen komme
ja danke ich war so stolz auf diesen
witz aber es macht mich auch ein
bisschen traurig andré zu sehen weil ich
mit all den leuten nichts mehr zu tun
habt man hat sich komplett auseinander
gelebt und so diese ersten jahre in
berlin die habe ich mit leuten verbracht
den ich heute nicht mal mehr zum
geburtstag gratuliere also das ist schon
ein bisschen set ist aber auch eine
lehre fürs leben manche menschen sind
halt einfach nicht für immer da manche
sind halt nur für eine phase da und das
ist auch okay so darf auch so sein weil
sonst hätte man glaube ich viel zu viele
freunde ja was macht nicht besteht und
wie komme ich heute auf meine video den
ich bin wie dieser mir der pianist der
sagt dass aliens im schlaf ihm die
kompositionen geben es kommt einfach
ganz ehrlich auch diese video idee das
sind einfach so blitze die denn du bist
mein gott ich muss dieses video drehen
du bist du beim videodreh schrägstrich
gamescom ganz vielleicht herr was ist
das bitte für ein zufall ja ich bin
dieses jahr auch auf der gamescom
nachdem ich das erste faq gedreht habe
bin ich zum ersten mal auf die video
days und gamescom gefahren seitdem hatte
ich keine gelegenheit mehr und dieses
jahr ist das erste mal nach fünf jahren
dass ich dann wieder hinfahren es gibt
natürlich keine videos mehr aber
trotzdem ist es soll ja leute falls ihr
auf der gamescom seite sagt hallo wenn
du zeitreisen könnte ist in welche
zeitepoche würdest du reisen und warum
ich würde zu newtons zeit gehen der typ
der die schwerkraft erfunden hat würde
den apfel auffangen bevor er auf seinem
kopf fällt und dann gab es keine
schwerkraft ist können alle fliegen
ich hab vergessen wie kreativ ich früher
war seit strange things will ich glaube
ich in die 80er
wie fühlst du dich wenn du fans triffst
bis jetzt damit zweimal passiert heute
für mich ist natürlich immer super fans
zu treffen
gerade wenn man ganz verdoppelt im
supermarkt steht in seiner jogginghose
und mit einer sonnenbrille drauf und
eigentlich nur hamburgs kaufen möchte
lemgo
ich finde schon cool fans zu treffen
manchmal liebig ist sogar wenn ich mich
mit denen dann richtig gut verstehe und
unterhalte dann denke ich mir du bist so
cool dann kriegst meine videos was ist
deine lieblingsserie of all time
[Musik]
immer noch game of thrones könntest du
dich vegetarisch vegan ernähren was für
musik hörst du und hast du vor
irgendwann einfach einzurichten
ich könnte mich auf keinen fall
vegetarisch ernähren weil wer einmal in
berlin war und die bürger in berlin
probiert hat weiß es nichts besseres
gibt als so ein richtig schönen bürger
sagte sie und ernährte sich drei jahre
vegetarisch und vegan musik gehöre ich
eigentlich alles von relax zu kings of
leon ich höre immer noch alles aber
zurzeit nur noch wenig und ja ein
postfach wird kommen wenn ich mich dann
irgendwann mal darum gekümmert haben ich
habe mir nie ein postfach eingerichtet
wollt ihr dass ich ein postfach aufmache
schreibt sie mir gerne mal in die
kommentare wohnst du schon immer in
berlin nein ich komme nicht aus hamburg
aber doch immer so schlecht wäre da habe
ich mir gedacht zieht man noch beliebig
wird auch so gern mal in köln wo ich
habe da mittlerweile so viele freunde
und menschen die ich eigentlich gerne
regelmäßiger sehen wollen würde
aber bis jetzt ist also noch nicht
passiert weil aber auch so ein städte um
zug gegen anstrengend ist wenn du dein
leben mit einem filmtitel beschreiben
könntest liebe das heißen ganz klar girl
jetzt bei mathe hausaufgaben every
single day mathe hausaufgaben waren
damals mein größtes problem heute wäre
der titel girl jetzt bei texas every
single day kannst du mal ein video mit
frolow machen und heute mit einem
special gast
es ist so komisch sein leben in youtube
videos dokumentiert zu haben weil man
immer wieder an alles erinnert wird
sobald man zurückschaut eigentlich
müsste ich mal wieder mit frodo machen
was für videos könnte man mit seinem
ex-freund drehen
ich bin ja wie bist du auf deinen namen
gekommen
den hat mir meine mama gegeben nein spaß
wo man das ist so kritsch wurde früher
war nie genannt mit 15 ok ich hab es da
viel zu lange erklärt ich wurde früher
war nie genannt das habe ich gehasst
dann war ich wanne mit 16 weil hh die
wanne ist voll und dann habe ich
angefangen meine social kanäle
aufzumachen und habe mich mal wanne
genannt einfach nur weil ich in einem
praktikum mal wannen gewaschen habe
rettet das ist die story und für alle
die es interessiert 20 169 60 39 lasagne
lacht gelb und für alle die es immer
noch interessiert 25 100 69 64 39
lasagne 9 geld so leute das war's mit
dem faq ich hoffe er wird spaß und
wünsche euch noch eine schöne woche
folgt mir gerne auf instagram falls ihr
noch mehr über mich erfahren wollt denn
da teile ich immer ein bisschen über
mein leben und was gerade so abgeht ich
wünsche euch eine wunderschöne woche
meiner apple watch hat sich gerade
gemeldet
ich habe eine nachricht von meinem
manager bekommen und sie hat sich nun
geöffnet was ist los mit dir
tschüssi copski eure mal wanne 25 wann
bin ich 25 geworden wann ist das
passiert bei dem apple watch placement
bei bieten
[Musik]